hello everyone and welcome to a video
all of you have been waiting for it's a
video where i will reveal the meaning
behind
the word agad mator and uh a lot of
people asked me this when i started the
youtube channel when i started uh
i did i did a bit more streaming than i
do now but uh
even in videos people were were like uh
what what what is agatha mata what does
it mean
uh how do you even pronounce it is it a
agony or is it
i don't know i i've heard so many
different pronunciations that
i i i can't even count but for those of
you who are still wondering it's
actually pronounced agad mator
and i'm now going to try to illustrate
what it
means and how it came to be so for this
uh
video i will be using uh windows paint i
haven't used it for like
20 years i think last time i used it was
in maybe 1999
uh i could be wrong but i i don't think
i've i've used that
all that much yeah in the past 20 years
but for the purposes of this video
i think it will do so basically what uh
we will do
is let's just uh try and uh
and uh you know break it down so sorry
that's not uh that's not a brush
this is a brush there we go all right
let's uh
choose the big one all right so we have
um agad mater
let's just put that on the board or in
this case this
uh pad all right there's g a d
not all that precise with the mouse but
what are you gonna do
and let's have there's there's an m
a t o r all right let's
let's do it like this t t-o-r all right
so there we have it so uh how do you uh
break it down so here we're just gonna
use uh three little
uh lines so we're gonna do it like this
we're gonna separate the a from gad and
we're going to separate the gad from
mato r so basically uh the word agar
matter consists of this
a g-a-d and m-a-t-o-r so uh to tell you
a little bit more about this we have to
go back
i think maybe some 20
20 years ago i think 20 years ago is
right uh
because then uh the the term was coined
then i had this uh
uh band with a colleague of mine uh we
we were
we were classmates basically and we had
this band
called uh god of it was sort of a rap
band we did some music we did some rap
and in croatian language gadovi means
bastards but
we didn't use the word bastards in in
that sense
it to us it meant something else it
meant uh you know
sort of in short basically uh respecting
each other and the members of our group
okay for the moment there were only two
of us in the group
uh later on another gentleman joined our
group rudy
so it was uh myself ivan and rudy and we
were the
uh we were gadovi you know so uh
basically it was a code of conduct or
maybe even uh
a way of living um uh so we we often
used to say
uh you know it's okay to be a bastard
towards everyone else but not towards
each other so it was a
you know something that was interesting
to us when we were 13 years old
and we listened to a lot of eminem we we
really enjoyed rap
we we tried to create some you know
rap music ourselves which still exists
but you're going to have a very hard
time
uh locating it on the internet so
basically uh when
when the group was formed it was called
gado meaning bastards and
in creation a single form of gadovi the
plural is god so there we have it
the gad is actually a bastard in
croatian
but to us it meant something else and
then uh when
rudy joined us there were three of us
and uh as
uh if you take our names a i and r uh
you get uh
uh the full extent of our of our over
group
and it happened uh i i remember we were
called
just gadovi or you know bastards uh but
then one day we were playing uh
basketball on the school play the
playground and
i think me or someone else had uh nikes
like uh
the air nike there was there was a brand
in those days i don't know if it still
exists
uh but it's a ir and then uh
i remember one gentleman that uh
currently makes the
best beer possible he actually has a
pub here in in my hometown uh said that
uh hey look look at your shoes it's like
a
i r uh and that's the name those are
like the first
names uh the the first letters of your
name so
uh a for antonio i for even and uh for
rudy
and r for rudy and then we said wow
that's really really something we we
could
change our name of our group from gado v
to air god of it but as we
uh wanted to sound very you know uh
profound we we did not call it air god
we but we called it ayurgadovi
and uh basically what uh uh every
every one of us in the group was uh uh
referred to as god the gad but
then uh when we added the uh air
uh to the god of it then i became agad
uh even became egot and
uh and then we operated under those
pseudonyms for quite some time i think
around maybe two years
uh all the way up to elementary school
after it finished and then
upon joining high school i think i think
i added the mater in the end to my agad
and then i became agatha mator and the
matar is sort of a
serbo croatian word for an old guy all
the dude um
i i often thought it uh maybe maybe even
uh referred to maybe being wise
an old wise guy so basically i combined
the ideas and then i formed the
the term agar matra so basically it
consists of a
g-a-d and m-a-t-o-r uh there you have it
so
gad means bastard but not in the sense
of the word that
bastard means uh it's something that was
uh
unless you were a part of that group
there is no way you could
grasp the meaning of the word but uh i i
hope i
illustrated it at least a bit on what it
means
the a is the first letter of my name
antonio
so agad not aged or aged or something
agad
and then after i became a bit older and
wiser
uh in those days that was 16 years old i
added the m-a-t-o-r
meaning sort of the the old wise guy or
just the old dude
and then the uh the coin the term was
coined i got mata
uh so yeah it's not maybe as mysterious
as you guys thought it would be but
i thought as uh you know you guys always
ask me
what does agamatra mean you know tell us
what does that matter mean and the first
time you asked me this i think my
channel had like maybe
2 000 subscribers and i jokingly said
and the uh
someone even sent me a live stream of
where i said it
that i will reveal the meaning of agatha
when the channel reached 1 million
subscribers
uh not really thinking that that would
ever happen but
now that it did happen i definitely owe
you guys an explanation on the
behind the meaning of agatha so there we
have it uh do share it with your friends
at the bar at the library that you now
know the true meaning of the word agat
mater
so that's that's the video hope you guys
enjoyed it once again
uh thank you all for uh for all the
support and it's
really really uh i i don't think i'm
just focusing now on making videos of
the tournament that's currently
happening in the world not really even
processing that
i've reached this insane number of 1
million subscribers
but i will prepare some sort of a stream
to you know celebrate it a little bit as
you should always
celebrate you know all the all the
little things in life
uh and um it can be a big celebration
because with the situation in the world
and everything you can't really do
gatherings and everything but maybe uh
you know i i i'll invite a
a person or two who are you know uh
properly scanned
and maybe we can do a live stream maybe
have some fun so we
will see what happens uh i i will keep
you guys informed
uh but yeah uh that's uh the that's the
video i hope you guys enjoyed it now you
know the true meaning of agatha mata
uh and yeah we're continuing with the
game so see you guys soon
have an excellent day